all right so Microsoft owns that studio
is in its entirety
any cancel project they don't go in
there and go delete in all the files and
everything all right so it's like
they're doing a meeting like we're
canceling this project order it what's
that order
delete the files delete the files delete
everything get me a coffee while you're
at it
but this stuff is
you know in in cold Frieza to be
Revisited at another time what what
y'all will hear in the news a lot and
you know I talked about it in nauseam
with Attic in the background you'll hear
something called economic downturn
that's code word for recession
all right we are in an economic downturn
so it's like that that's that Spider-Man
artistic change
but this this stuff is you you see it
you want these games but economically
you can't afford these games